[Music]
when you're a kid you can't choose
certain things like your last name you
can't choose you can't choose you what
you look like you can't choose your
genetics you can't choose your last name
that's a very accurate statement um
actually sorry it's not very accurate
it's just accurate yeah it can't be very
active that's true there aren't degrees
of accuracy my association with my last
name long
is um a very complicated one we have a
name that is also used in the world it's
a very common name
it's a descriptive name obviously it's a
um you know it's an adjective
so i i've always been aware of you know
hearing that in the world and you know
people make puns and people make jokes
about it like oh
life is short um with justin long but it
paid off it allowed you to have a ton
for your podcast uh 40 plus years into
the future that's true which is about to
start right now what's actually started
i can't wait okay well let's do it then
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening to life for short i am
your host justin long
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
it is
co-hosted and produced by you
cr christian long why did i stumble on
your name i used to tell people that my
uncle was howie long when i was a kid um
did i ever the great football player yes
for those
great commentators not only a great
football player but extraordinarily
handsome well that's why football
players the kids have a hard time
believing it yeah known well maybe when
i was really young they believed it but
then i reached a certain age where it's
like
maybe third grade fourth grade where
people were like you must have been
adopted that guy has like a beautiful
jawline there's no way you're related to
him well doesn't he now also have like
an equally impressive well not he's a
very athletic son chris long chris long
that's his son yeah chris long is howie
long's son yeah
oh i didn't know that there's chris for
the eagles and there's another long he
has two
there's a there's nothing i don't think
so there's another
nfl player but yeah you're right when we
were kids like i would always take note
of how we like i'd have i felt like a
special connection to him because of our
name
howie long and yet yeah he was one of
the most impressive physical specialists
and now his son chris long not only is a
great oh he's a football player
but he's incredibly philanthropic yes
and outspoken you're a great person he
really is yeah why are we talking about
the last name long and philanthropic
great people nice well it's a double
tie-in yeah did you mean to do that no i
stumbled into it uh thanks chris long
also thanks for everything you do um and
thanks howie long for the years of
entertainment and enjoyment watching him
play he he continues to entertain but
yeah and i don't want to derail that
great segue of yours
but um i'll tell you why to answer your
question from 40 seconds ago
why are we talking about the name long
well ah
just re remind people uh because our
guest today
is
has a similar name
uh she is named long long
gloria
eva longoria is our guest today and
it's not two separate names her name
isn't eva long no and now i'm gloria
immediately self-conscious of her
hearing this really like stumbling setup
and introduction
maybe you know maybe she'll skip this
part i hope so just go right right to
her stuff i wonder if most people skip
this part i wonder i don't think so um
i don't know but um i hope she has i
shouldn't say too much about that no
no because it's your part uh ring people
just like
uh and then they wait till like a din
um anyway uh what eva longoria is
one of the
most accomplished people i think i think
she's as accomplished as you can be
certainly one of the most philanthropic
people in show business
yeah philanthropic but also like i mean
like the least impressive thing about
her is her name that she has a name
similar to yours you know yeah i know
what do we i mean it's still italian it
is so it's
technically appropriate but you're right
she although her name is quite
as you'll hear quite impressive and and
she has a really interesting lineage and
connection to that name that we will get
into she um
she was part of the
global smash hit desperate housewives
yeah and we got rose to superstardom
from that show
and since then she has
become a household name and she is the
face of l'oreal yeah and she's a
producer and a director and a
philanthropist and she really
it's really not an overstatement to say
she does it all i would say yeah and she
strikes me as like the opposite of a
desperate housewife
you know she seems uh
just incredibly driven and accomplished
and and housewives can be driven oh yeah
i guess so in in the more nefarious ways
yeah that's true um
all right well but but your point
remains i agree with you there's a
pyramid and she doesn't seem like a
desperate house not at all um she is
someone that i i and you see she's
out there she's in beauty campaigns and
like you said a lot of philanthropy and
i've she's just always seems to be
present in my like uh whenever i connect
with pop culture have you met her before
i've never met her i
um i we follow each other on instagram
so i've which is that that's the weird
deceptive thing about instagram you you
get to feel like you know the person and
and you you know about details of their
lives and i was like well i don't know
her and yet i do know she just got back
from a trip and then she worked out
yesterday it's
you know did you like the the workout
video um or her most recent picture are
you excited
i am a good liker you're a good liker in
general i miss a lot and for this is for
this for the few people anyone i i do
follow uh please know uh that i i miss a
lot like i go i'll go off instagram for
a couple days and you know then it like
stuff piles up and i feel like weird
liking something from three days ago
then you seem like a stalker
yes yeah and it seems like you search
for that right i too like them yeah well
i know um the politics of instagram is
very complicated it is and and and
sometimes when it comes to like a woman
like eva i if it's something like a
workout video like her in like spandex i
feel a little like strange liking that
like a little like it might seem like
ooh i'm like ogling her or something you
shouldn't she did it i know but well
that also i should talk about that in
therapy because that must mean
that maybe there is some
truth to that for now let's get into the
show okay okay um i was uh yes i i was
so excited to talk to her and um we have
mutual friends and so i i knew she we
get it you run in the same circles as
evil longoria and you have a similar
last name um yeah he or she okay you're
right i'm digressing a lot of
digressions and uh she doesn't deserve
any digressions she deserves just to get
right into it so here it is
um my my introduction to the ubiquitous
and and very talented uh driven
passionate eva longoria
life could be a dream
[Music]
justin oh my god
i know it felt like i didn't want to do
your podcast because we couldn't get a
time
but i really really do
no no it's so funny because you uh if
there was a moment where i thought is
she now did she just say that to be
polite it's like a like an instagram
politeness like hey i'd love
i'd like to do that sometime and then
when i called you out on i was like okay
anytime i was like i have nothing to do
then you probably realize you're the
busiest human being in show business
no i you don't even understand when um
back in the day
uh yeah what like early 2000's i always
was like oh my god if i married justin
long i would be evil long instead of eva
longoria
you know what i've had that thought i
i've thought about that justin longoria
long it'd be better for you i guess yeah
yeah but that would be the only benefit
the only benefit of marrying you
you take the good with the bad but i
remember that oh yeah i was like oh my
god there's an actor who has half of my
last name
i well yes and i i was going to ask you
if you ever get evan longoria there's
that long yeah you don't understand yeah
his rook a year
like desperate housewives was exploding
during his rookie year or something
coincided and uh everybody was like in
every interview he ever did was like are
you related to evil and gorilla and he's
like no i'm not
are you related to people he's like no
i'm not and finally like you know he had
all this accomplishment he goes if one
more person
asks me if i'm related to [ __ ] evil
and i was like oh my god i felt so bad
so i sent him um i sent him a bottle of
champagne congratulating him for rookie
of the year and i said i'm so sorry our
names are so similar
oh that's so funny that's funny he sent
me back a jersey you know longoria
that's so awesome i was like no
i don't mind it i'm like no i heard an
interview you really i you do i've heard
it i heard it in your voice you've def
you more than minded yeah
yeah i i asked um there's a there's a
couple
longs i have never met uh i met shelley
long oh yeah i worked with her briefly
and um she's somebody who i watched
growing up i just knew of her she was
you know since i was a kid and and uh
she was aware of that that was that was
a moment where i thought oh wow i've
i've i'm out there in the world enough
for shelley long to know who i am are
you guys related
not at all not at all but i don't know
what is that
well long was lange uh a couple
generations ago and they were
embarrassed of the nazis
uh yes yes i think it was changed before
the nazis really it was when they were
coming to power so it was before it was
known but it was
known enough in german jewish circles
that they anglicized that's oh my god
that's amazing my name is never oh no
you know what my name was
was ll
yangoria and it was celtic
l l oh so it's not his it's not of
mexican well originally it was celtic
and like viking i mean oh wow yeah back
in the day
did they get down to mexico the vikings
no well well they got to europe and then
spain went to new space right which
right mexico and then mexico montezuma
mexico became texas yeah
oh wow and so you i didn't know this
that you
you didn't speak english no for a long
time i was for spanish i never spoke
spanish
oh you're kidding me yeah you wait you
grew up only speaking english only
speaking english yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm
from i'm from texas i'm a texan i'm a
texas mexican
oh i'm 13th generation
american
and so we this is what i'm saying like
we were we've been in in
mexico which was we were in new spain
since 1603
and and then it became
mexico and it became france for a minute
and then it became republic of texas and
it became united states and so my family
was under five different flags without
ever moving oh my god those longorius
they were really re resilient i guess
yes they they or they assimilated easily
while we uh never crossed the border the
border crossed us yes that's right yes
oh my god yeah so people are always
thinking that they're like generations
when
yeah your parents are mexican no your
grandparents are mexican no your
great-great-grandparents i was like no
1836 so i think it was that's when oh my
god mexico became texas
when there was yeah uh which by the way
a little bit of history it became the
republic of texas for a minute because
lincoln did not want to uh accept texas
in the union because it was a slave
state and he didn't want another slave
state in
in the union and uh so that's why it was
a country for a second
and then we became that's why we were
the republic of texas oh interesting
then we were texas
so that that was was that after the
mexican american war then is that yes it
was carved out polk is that
that's all the time we have
i get so excited when i know things yeah
yes james pope i actually okay about
that
well so that sort of makes up for me
thinking that you only spoke spanish for
most of your life when in fact you never
never spoke spanish no i
spoke i mean yeah we didn't speak it
well because we were forced to
assimilate and so my parents spoke it to
each other but they were like don't
speak the spanish
oh the forbidden tongue
oh wow yeah so but wasn't wasn't it was
it spoken i imagine there was a lot of
there were a lot of mexican americans uh
in corpus christi i would imagine you
grew up around a lot yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah i mean it was it was very
hispanic in in texas and uh it the funny
thing was like i
had to go to a different school when i
was in like third grade i got
i was in the gifted and talented program
and well it doesn't surprise me and i
made they made me go to a school across
town in the rich neighborhood and i was
like yeah man
and it was the first time i got on the
bus and somebody goes oh my god she's
mexican
and i was like what's that
yeah i had never you were like you
probably thought it was a cool new thing
i was just like
who me i don't
think so because because everybody was
mexican where i was growing up yes yeah
yeah it was never pointed out yeah i
would never point it out until i went to
like
a white neighborhood and oh my god yeah
and they were like
she's the mexican and i was like i
remember getting on the bus oh and
everybody had a a pop-tart
and i had a bee i had a bean burrito for
breakfast
and everybody goes i was like oh my god
what's that and they were like what's
that and i was like it's a white burrito
[Laughter]
and i begged my mom i went home and i
was like mom please buy me a pop-tart i
don't want to have a baby
and she's oh my
did she she was like oh my god those
things are like three dollars for four
pieces like no yeah yeah yeah i never
got them either but i wanted i know it
was such forbidden fruit pop-tarts
uh for me too yeah i always wanted crap
i wanted junk food my parents and now
looking back like i had the i've been so
lucky to have had parents who were like
you know gave like yours the nutritious
food yeah i wanted the [ __ ] i wanted the
twinkies and the crepes oh man who
doesn't who even my son who's three is
like
they just
want it like that he doesn't even know
it he doesn't even he's never even had a
gummy bear and he just all he knows is
he wants it
yeah he knows he can't have it that's
why he wants it yeah
how many kids do you have i have one
child that i've
birthed uh uh he's three years old and i
have three step children and that's
right yeah my husband's children
oh wow what what was that so so you
inherited so right away wow
what was what was that what was that
like oh my god it was it was so it was
fun because you know as a step parent
you like
you participate
but yeah you don't have a vote so it was
i was like okay this is fun yes yes and
so and when i met my husband they were
she he had a 17 year old and two
nine-year-olds twins
and uh and so now now uh his oldest
daughter's 25 she just got married and
now the twins are 18 and it's like it's
just been amazing to
like see them become like these little
children like i remember them having a
minion birthday cake you know
like i'm married i was like what
wow wow well but what if they had the
minion party like two years ago
they just loved it yeah it crosses all
generations
um
and you had three you had three sisters
yes
and and the youngest of four then what
what was your childhood like i mean
aside from
you know once you then had to go to that
the white rich school did did they
eventually accept you and the wheels
came off right now yeah that was good i
was like scarred for like no i grew up
in uh yeah a household of women my three
sisters four girls my mom my mom had
nine sisters wow so it was like all ants
yeah i mean it was like a family woman
when i had santi i was like i don't even
know what to do with this little penis
because we had never you know been like
it was
we had all women all women i'm like how
do you clean this thing how does this go
so you just removed it yeah you had it
had it removed i'm sorry you can't do
that yourself
what do i do with this little penis
it's like
it'd be funny if someone just tuned in
for this now or just heard someone
hearing this now
i love i love those sound bites yeah
when you're on the phone
the whole the research i did about
circumcision i you know oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah and and you know the in
cleaning and and the uh all of it was
very new to me because i grew up with
women
do you have you have brothers i have a
penis yes i have a little penis
yes
i hate to read books about cleaning
little penises too for my
my own
my own edification for your own hygiene
um
no i have two brothers yeah i have
another guy so there you go yeah yeah my
my mother was very accustomed to
cleaning penises
i should ask her actually i'm curious
like because that is that's a good
question like how would you know that i
she wouldn't have known that um
i don't think up until then she had
cleaned a piece
i should ask her i'm gonna ask her you
know what's funny if i got her on the
phone now
she will
ask you know what i might and ask her
mom
wait who's the oldest not you you're in
the middle you're a middle child
middle
oh you don't yeah
my
you know what
[Laughter]
you don't strike me as a middle child
oh really i i take that as a compliment
yeah maybe i shouldn't no i think you
should middle children always take
things as compliments yeah i'm i'm a
middle yeah what is what were your
what what tendencies do you have that
people say oh of classic youngest child
i think with the fact that i'm an
actress and like look at me
yeah yeah i need to be seen and hurt
my mom said my mom's like it's you know
social media she's like you would have
loved social media when you were young
because i was like they would take a
picture or a polaroid and i would go am
i in it am i in it am i in it and i
remember saying that all the time did
you get me did you get me did you get me
oh wow interesting and your siblings
weren't like that your sisters aren't no
as a matter of fact i thought i was
adopted because um i look nothing like
my sisters my sisters are like blonde
hair hazel eyes really light skin
whoa they're all all blonde when they
were born and i came out with a head of
black hair and really dark skin and i
have the darkest eyes in my family
and um and so and they would and they
would like make fun of me they were like
we found you in a trash can you're not
our sister we found you at the hospital
oh they were so i was called la prieta
feya which is the ugly dark one
and oh my gosh yeah it was like
literally and people were like oh who
called you that i go my mother my mother
called me this not like bullies like my
mom and my sisters
and uh and
and like and growing up like they were
they were all in band and played the
flute and i was like i was in
cheerleading they all you know
did this thing and i did this thing wow
and then as as adults like they all
three have like the same health issues i
don't and and so i did this like dna
test uh or this show this uh you know
that show oh yes the doctor yes what's
with american lives
yes oh how cool pbs
they don't reveal anything to you until
they sit you down on camera and dr gates
kept saying you're gonna be
so surprised
and i said oh great i can't wait this is
gonna be exciting and he's like no
listen even not in a good way
all right you're gonna you're gonna be
floored are we rolling are we rolling
okay great and i you you didn't get
nervous yeah and then i started to get
nervous
and he's like because they like to get
your reaction on camera yes oh i was
like god i was like okay and then he's
like i just i can't even i can't even
contain myself and i go okay hang on
hang on hang on i was like is my is my
father my father
like that's all i yeah yeah yeah that's
what i would ask actually
yes because you know they did the dna
from all my family and i thought he was
going to say you were adopted like i
really yeah for sure like he's gonna
it's this big building he's gonna tell
me that on camera and i'm gonna be like
i knew it
i knew it and um
yeah yeah your father was pol pot
like what
jesus you're related to aaron burr like
yeah yeah
oh my god
but no it was uh he's like no you're
you're related to your siblings i was
like i mean my mom and dad so i was like
well what was the big buildup that i was
the most american
person he had ever interviewed i had
been like the earliest person
to settle in 1603 oh you know he's like
everybody's interviewed has been you
know arrived in the 1800s in new york
yeah yeah maybe 1920 you know or
something holy [ __ ] 1603
oh the earliest he could track he was
like you're the earliest like we've
actually tracked back and like
and
and who was that do you know who that
person yes he was pedro longoria he was
11 years old he was my 13th great
grandfather and they have the letter
that he wrote to the king saying may i
join my uncle who was the magistrate in
new spain
oh my god so you had to ask permission
from the king to go to new spain and
then he wrote he went on a boat by
himself at 11
to go meet holy [ __ ] [ __ ] with no sound
i wonder what no cell phone oh
they didn't have cell phones no wait
so how did he document his trip how did
he
show people every day this constant
that's getting crazy what do you ate
it's
yeah exactly
it's crazy to me i saw a couple i've
been seeing couples now
uh just on their phone like at dates on
dates
on the phone on the phones and then
getting together for a picture then they
smile for for a second for the selfie
that's my favorite move you know like a
big smile and then back to like
somber
that's why i was so bad at responding to
you because i'm not uh yeah
i bet i get it also you you do
so much i mean you've always struck me
as such an industrious per you're always
doing you do so much uh where did that
work ethic come from was that from your
family yeah that was for my mom my mom
yeah you know she raised four girls my
oldest sister special needs uh she had a
full-time job she
was like a human taxi like drove me to
cheerleading drove my sister to band
dropped my sister off at work took my
sister to therapy
and was at a full-time job and had
dinner on the table every night at 6 p.m
like a homemade dinner isn't that
remarkable i think about that now when i
cook a meal it takes it takes me
it takes hours and it's the project and
but but that on top of anything else if
i have to drop a letter off at the post
you know that's it for me but to raise
to do all of that to run around with
those kids kids and stuff so i today i
still feel like i'm not doing enough
like i'm like i'm not doing enough
oh my god how do how does your how do
your siblings now feel about
your success in in this industry like
what are they what are they it
had the ugly dark one succeeded
i remember when i uh
there was a couple of of milestones in
that
journey of like guys yeah guys come on i
think i have some potential to my
sister's yeah but i entered a beauty
pageant it was actually a skull a
scholarship pageant at uh when i was
like 19 20 19. was that miss miss corpus
christi it was it was miss texas a m
which led to miss corpus christi but i
remember going like i couldn't pay for
my senior year at school and a
girlfriend's like why don't you join the
scholarship pageant it'll be really fun
and i'm like a beauty pageant she's like
yeah basically but it's called
scholarship page and i was like i know
nothing about that world and in texas
like i should have been groomed like
pageants and football oh it's totally
yes oh my god from birth
yeah
yeah
exactly
exactly and so i was like okay so i
called my mom and i was like mom i'm
gonna i need a dress i didn't even know
it was called a gown i said i need a
dress
um
i'm gonna enter this pageant she goes oh
honey i don't think that's a good idea
for you
cause she thought i was she thought i
was gonna lose she was like oh honey i
don't yeah you're the ugly dark one yeah
oh honey nobody's nobody's gonna vote
for you and i go i don't think people
vote mom i think i think it's like a
panel okay and then nobody came by the
way nobody came
and uh you mean i'm of your i'm on your
face yeah yeah yeah because i was like i
mean they're like they didn't want to
see you embarrass yourself they're like
yeah it was nice of them yes exactly
and then i oh my and then i won and i
won this thing
and uh and so i was like okay uh my mom
i won and she's like you did i mean even
my sisters were like oh my god my
sisters were like what
well there must have not have been a lot
of competition and i was like oh my god
there it was a lot of come it was miss
teen so and so and miss teen
so and so was in it i i don't know but i
won so then i had to go to miss corpus
christi because you have to keep it's
like a pyramid scheme
yeah yeah
that's how they get you they pretended
that you won
so you don't but you must have thought
so how do you have how did you have the
confidence that you i mean i know like
that wasn't the result of confidence
necessarily but just to be someone who
wants to be seen and entertained
with that how did you have that kind of
confidence with the constant no negative
reasons no no i set the bar low i i i
saw that fifth place was was books
like they would pay for your books and
then fourth place was like books tuition
and then third place was books tuition
board and first and then and then the
first place was like books tuition board
stipend you know
and so i was like if i could just get
fifth place
i think i'll i think i can manage the
rest of the expenses and then i remember
when they go fifth runner-up is you know
jamie whatever and i was like oh yeah
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
oh man and then and then i go maybe
maybe i got fourth maybe i got fourth
and i remember standing by some miracle
hail mary i think i might get four
and uh and i didn't get fourth and i was
like
all right and honestly then i was like
okay i didn't um i didn't do anything
and then when i won i was like oh my god
i get to pay my senior year that's all i
thought about i wasn't wow wow they're
like ma'am we got to put the crown on
you honey and i was like yeah oh yeah
yeah the thing and the oh the thing and
the crown and the banner and the yeah
they go
right right you should do your walk now
and i was like where where am i going
what am i doing like
other people would have known this i
it was like you were robbing a bank
you're like i just want to get my [ __ ]
get out of here i just want to like hold
on to my stuff i drove my money you keep
the crown keep yeah just get my tuition
check please because you're going to
realize you made a mistake and i want to
make sure i'm gone by the time you do
i i always think that in football when
they run to win it's clearly like out of
bounds or something and they and the
coach is about to challenge it he's got
like the red flag out i always think
like go hurry up i'd hurry up and snap
the ball so quickly you know so they
didn't have time to like second guess it
so
at that point were your parents like
whoa this is like this is
a legitimate thing like good for you did
you ever get that did you ever hear that
no they were proud i mean they loved it
they loved me and they were proud they
were like good for you you did that
thing and then um so then i go to miss
corpus christi and i win that
and uh and that in that prize package
was a trip to l.a
and that's that's where this all started
because it was like oh this talent
competition and i was like talent nobody
said anything about talent
hold on wait what did you so did you
think so that's when you had to be like
well what is my talent you had to come
up with the talent no i mean it was
acting or modeling i mean it was like
yeah yeah it was like a talent
search i i i don't know what it was but
they were like you can do a monologue
and i was like what a what
uh and then
uh
and so
i came i honestly was like i just wanted
a trip to l.a i was like that'll be fun
i've never been to i've never been out
of texas like much less
los angeles
for yeah for 13 generations you never
and not no longoria had left since pedro
that's crazy
i'm still i'm thinking about 11 year old
pedro coming over like what was
for you know i wonder what he was after
i mean maybe it was just that like a new
world i know
i don't know it sounded kind of
scandalous it sounded like he was
escaping something from
oh
like
desperate housewives yeah yeah yeah i
mean i i
that's the narrative i've put in my own
yeah
no i don't know i mean i think it was a
time
in which you know it was exciting
i mean i don't know i don't know what
big dreams could an 11 year old have
oh when i was 11 i wanted to my big
dream was to see an r-rated movie
i mean i i can't imagine doing that
that's crazy i went to rhode island once
i grew up in connecticut and i was like
wow
this is wild you know
um
that's as far as i go i was like pedro
you were like
i had never been out of texas so i came
to atlanta and then i go into this um
talent audition and uh and all these
managers and agents were like oh my god
this was you gotta remember this was
like 1990
eight
it was like live in la vida ricky martin
and jlo had just like
exploded and so they were like latin i
was like oh
uh i think i'm gonna stay i think i'm
gonna be an actor i mean like that like
one day just one day no [ __ ] you had
never it had never crossed your mind
never i had just graduated college
and
i was that's wild well i can get a job i
have a degree that's all i thought like
i was like oh my god hey you have been
working at wendy's yeah my whole high
school my whole high school i worked at
wendy's i was a head cashier at the
drive-through
did you ever get like wild customers did
you ever get like
weirdo customers at the windows i was
wondering always the windows always
always always now i look back and i'm
like oh my god that was such a dangerous
job because we'd be there you know i was
like
15
at a drive-through and drunk people at
midnight and it was like oh yeah um but
i tell you i mean that's also i think
everybody should work free frosties free
frosties free fries fries and frosties
sorry i interrupted you ava yeah yeah no
everybody should work in fast food
or service yeah yeah you gotta show up
and you gotta climb in and you gotta
wear a uniform and that uniform have to
wash it at night and then i gotta get it
ready in the morning like it was a whole
thing yep and you gotta clean out i mean
cleaning some of that crap too like
cleaning out the the dairy any anything
dairy-related to clean is well
the grill like the grease and all that
grease and i was like i would just go
home smelling like a french fry oh my do
you ever go to wendy's now and think do
you have that moment yeah i bet oh
always and i'm like can i get i know i
know i need some fresh fries i know you
dropped those four minutes ago i'd
rather have one now
you know
oh yeah you know how to order drop a
fresh drop of fresh meat don't
don't give me what's already on the
grill that's been there for an hour um
can you say that are you allowed to say
that oh i do i don't know if i'm allowed
[Music]
i'm glad we're sitting down for this
because listeners you can get forty
percent off your first order when you
join thrive market today and a free gift
worth over fifty dollars well first we
should say what it is okay okay thrive
market do you mind if i say no thrive
market is an online membership-based
market on a mission to make healthy
living easy and affordable for everyone
actually i do mind now i would like to
say sorry you can do a monthly or annual
membership whatever suits you i recently
joined we both recently yes
i've really been enjoying it in fact
yesterday i can shout out a delicious
thing i just thought yeah
a keto friendly
vegetarian
chili it was delicious i had it for
lunch and and chomps beef sticks not
vegetarian but delicious they have a lot
of great vegetarian vegan options and a
lot of healthy essentials everything
from sustainable meat and seafood to
non-toxic cleaning and beauty products
it's all delivered right to your door
and this is a cool thing if you find a
price lower elsewhere they will even
match it they donate a membership to a
family in need too how cool is that can
your grocery store do that now
now it can when you go to
thrivemarket.com
long join today to get 40 off your first
order and a free gift worth over 50
that's t-h-r-i-v-e
market
dot com slash long to get forty percent
off your first order and a free gift
over fifty dollars thrive market dot com
slash long
on this show we talk a lot about how our
guests have struggled with mental health
and if you can relate to that if you've
had your own struggles
this might be something you want to look
into it's called cerebral it's an online
mental health service that offers
prescription medication counseling and
therapy for anxiety depression adhd
insomnia and many more things cerebral
is one of the few services that provides
prescription medication online through a
licensed provider and ships that
medication straight to your door you can
skip the pharmacy lines you'll get
unlimited messaging with your care team
with the cerebral mobile app it's like
having your personal care team wherever
you are you can connect with your
counselor and therapist on your own
schedule and through your laptop or the
cerebro mobile app you'll get affordable
treatments that are one-third the price
of traditional therapy you can get
treatment options that are available
with or without insurance even if you're
out of network they'll provide you with
the necessary paperwork so you can
easily submit a claim for listeners of
this program you can receive 65 off your
first month of medication management and
care counseling at cerebral dot com
slash long that's cerebral dot com slash
long for 65 off your first month of
medication management and care
counseling go to cerebral.com
long for 65 off your first month so join
cerebral today on their mission to make
quality mental health care accessible
and affordable for all go to
cerebral.com
long for 65 off your first month
[Music]
you are also one of the most
like charitable philanthropic people i
know you work with too many i think to
talk about but
how how do you get involved in all of
that what is your criteria oh yeah wait
so funny bono i'm just i don't know bono
but
yeah i also worked with you at wendy's
fun okay i came through the
drive-through one day
yeah
yes i'd like a dr drop the fresh one i
can't do a bono impression don't don't
be giving me any of those older fries
that's a terrible idea is it old and
iron
irish
well he
what would be wrong with that
um he is irish i believe but that's
still the kind of you to call that an
irish act
he's all he's old um he was an old
family no
but uh but but i will say so so
my philanthropy started at home i mean
my my older sister was mentally this is
mentally disabled and so
we
always
went to all these community programs
like um you know the boys and girls club
had karate night and my mom
take my sister and they were like oh
we can't really handle
you know a special needs person
uh unless somebody's with her my my
mom's like yeah these three other girls
they're volunteering so we we
we
you were made to volunteer you were
forced you were a forced volunteer we
were forced to volunteer in order for my
sister what a good thing oh man i tell
you to instill the greatest gift you can
instill in children very early on is the
idea of volunteerism
i mean yeah yeah all my earliest
memories are special olympics boys and
girls club salvation army the like
that's all i can remember is like you
know at thanksgiving like all my
memories are about being at a food
kitchen i don't even remember us having
a wow like a turkey at home like i'm
like yeah i think we did that
but i i remember sleeping so great at
the special olympics waking up and then
going back taking a like i just remember
that's my earliest memory is being uh
being a hugger at the special olympics
oh wow that's so i think my sister was
there
wow so she was participating she was
participating in individuals so every
time
she participated we had to volunteer my
mom would make us volunteer and so i
just was like
i i loved volunteering so much i thought
it was a job i was like when i grew up
i'm going to be a volunteer oh oh wow
did we did your other siblings feel that
way and were you guys all close to you
all kind of like yeah we were all very
close even though they're mean to me
we're still very close we're very close
because we're very close in age too
we're all like a year and a half apart
so we were all like you know we would
play monopoly together because you need
four people you know we would play simon
together yeah you evened it out you even
never even did everything else um and so
we were helped so much by charities i
was like who's charity she's so nice
like i like her
[Laughter]
what's a mexican what's a mexican and
who's true
these are things i want to know exactly
yes who is she's so nice she's so nice
and so she's really got her hands full
yeah
yeah and so that's how kind of my my
philanth philanthropic
heart i think is is really in my dna
it's like i was i was born into my
sister's world i really don't know any
other world i don't know i remember you
know we can't go on vacation without
unless it was a place lisa could go we
couldn't go to
uh you know a restaurant that was too
loud because it would bother lisa like
everything was dictated by my sister and
i think it was such a gift growing up
and i just it never felt like a bur like
as a child you never remember feeling
like burdened by it or oh yeah i'm sure
i'm sure i mean i was a bratty kid so
i'm sure
yeah i remember like oh mom you know do
we have to go there or you know yeah for
sure
but
looking back on it i'm like i'm glad i
totally did that do you find yourself
pressed for time are you are you very
um
[Music]
regulated with time like you do very
very good
very efficient very efficient there's
not like a
minute i waste in
the day i think there's 48 hours in a
day
and
um oh wow yeah and especially like i
love to cook like for you you were
saying how
it um
you take it it's the majority of my day
if you cook someone's major i'm like you
know i'm uh i've already prepared four
days ahead i was like okay i'm gonna top
this yeah while santi and i are watching
a movie i'm gonna chop the beans and
then we're still together and he's gonna
help me and we're gonna like i'm
constantly merging things together you
know i have that one hour drive so i'm
going to do my conference calls so that
when i get home i don't have to do them
i mean
i'm constantly you know if i have to go
to
work i have to go to paris for l'oreal
and [ __ ] real i'm like we're going to
stop over and bordeaux we're going to go
do a [ __ ] wine trip because we're
going to connect it like a very
efficient way
every day yes
that is so impressive that is and yet
you don't seem like harried or you're
you seem so present that that usually
with people like that they're like uh
they're thinking about the next thing
but you seem very i'm actually uh i'm
actually texting here
okay
i would not have known it's so
impressive
uh
and so you were you must have always
been like that i mean you must have been
like that as a kid too
i feel like i but my mom was like that i
mean my mom was like
i'm going to go to the bank you're going
to go next door we're going to drop this
mail off you're going to go across the
street while i go to the bank and we're
going to pick you up on the way back and
you know it was like a constant tetris
of
chores yes
what got you interested in uh is it
kidney kinesis
the the study of
movement movement of the body yeah
yeah what what how did you get into
that's what you majored in are you
laughing because of my research my like
weak like wikipedia research yes
all right
yes yes kinesiology well no i mean i was
going to be a physical therapist my
dream
was to work for the dallas cowboys like
i was like i want to be oh no way sports
therapist for the dallas cowboys yeah i
mean i wasn't totally into fitness i was
like ripped and i you wouldn't tell now
but i was ripped in college i was yeah
oh yeah you've really let yourself a
personal trainer yeah i did that i
taught uh aerobics classes i was a
cheerleader i was a gymnast i was a
track runner i was there so i was really
into fitness and um no you you post
stuff like that sometimes the thing you
did the other day where you were hopping
up on that thing that's real i was like
really impressive
on the trampoline
yeah but it is that's hard to do i did i
tried that once i almost broke my nose
yeah you it was so your body control was
really amazing
so and you were also a cowboys fan yeah
you grew up huge
yeah
i remember
i you know if you want to be a physical
therapist you like got to work your way
up and go to work and you know and i
wanted to work with athletes and so i'm
like yeah yeah yeah i was like working
with the football team
taping ankles like that was like you got
to start somewhere and i'm like uh-huh
taping before football game so i'm
taping 50 guys ankle i mean i'm just
like guy
and i'm like
yeah i don't think i want to do this
why
why that
sounds so you'd rather be cleaning the
the grill at wendy's that sounds more i
mean literally i was like
i don't yeah i don't i don't think i
don't think this is what i'm going to do
and it coat was it the combination of
feet smelling and the way they behaved
probably probably yeah and i was like a
pretty girl in the locker room and it
was like right
god
how long is it gonna like
but um so and it coincided with me my
trip to l.a so i like just graduated
college with my kinesiology degree
and i was going to la so i was like yeah
i don't want to do that but i have this
degree but i think i'm going to act
and then oh my gosh and um
and then acted and then you know came
here
was an extra for two years i just wanted
to be on a set and i i was like that
annoying extra that you soon as you're
on set and they're like hi hi
hi oh my god i'm such a big fan so what
do you guys do why is that called a mark
what's what's checking the gate what
does that mean what is it my my my
favorite is they told us we're not
allowed to talk to you and i whenever i
hear that i'm like oh that's absurd of
course you're you are that's crazy of
course you are and then occasionally i
regret it yeah yeah can somebody take
her back to holding that's what i always
got yeah
that's
she's out again and i would just do
extra work to steal toilet paper and
food
oh yeah and also the craft service
apples bananas and like
i still i'm not kidding i still find
myself taking rolls of toilet paper and
uh hand soap i'll take hand soap if
there's a bunch of extras yeah well
during the early in the pandemic like
it was the hand sanitizer
and lysol wipes was like
uh uh you know
scarce so i had a i had a loyal shoot it
was like right before lockdown
and uh there was some lysol wipes and
i'm like we're taking the lysol wipes
get the lysol wipes and we took all of
them out of the room and we took them
all and it was like
oh my god it would have been such a
funny scandal if you had been busted if
you had been caught stealing uh
so what was your first so you get an
agent from the um
what was it called miss
to la
no no it was just a
a a talent competition here it was just
it was just like
it was called something i am i am ta i
one of those
conventions i don't even know
yeah but there happened to be but there
were like representatives yeah yeah
by the way
i had a a a modeling portfolio because
that was part of my little uh
uh price package as well you got your
your headshot done and
i got so many callbacks from like
wilhemina and ford modeling and i was
like oh my god oh my god and i would
show up and they were like wait are you
5-2 and i was like yeah they're like no
next
and i was like what the f and so i
didn't know you had to be tall to be a
model i mean i didn't know anything oh
yes well you also must have been so i
just keep thinking about what your
parents what your mom and your sister
said called you the the ugly dark one
you must have been so
you must be confused you must have been
like i don't understand why all these
people
think of me this way you know it's also
probably how you cultivated such a good
personality because you
didn't feel like yeah you couldn't i do
have a great personality
yeah but no i do think though that's why
i developed a comedic personality is
because yeah yeah it wasn't the pretty
one and i was never the pretty one my
sisters were gorgeous people would come
up to my mom in a mall and go your
daughters are beautiful
and who's this
and i would be like
hello hello so i was like
hey like i was like going to be the
funny one if i wasn't the pretty one
i was going to be the funny one
have you seen the kristen wiig sketch on
snl where she's like and then there's
she's got the little baby hands she's
like and then there's me
it's like
that was me that's so wild so at what
point did they come around at what point
were they did they ever say give her a
moment with them where they were like
well i guess we were wrong or like not
wrong but like when i got when i got
l'oreal i i i
got l'oreal
as an uh as a
what a thing um yeah they chose me as a
spokesperson yeah and yeah
and i was like
look at me now i mean it literally was
like nothing else and then i got l'oreal
and they were like oh my god you look
beautiful i was like yeah yeah because
i'm worth it
um but
[Laughter]
but you didn't feel the need to gloat or
to throw no i didn't but i did
no
[Laughter]
what what about the young how did the
young and the restless i'm so interested
in
soap operas and anyone who does soap
operas for that long
um
they're first of all so good at
memorizing lines that's a crazy thing
that you had to be you have to know them
like that yeah you do 40 pages a day i
mean it's that's a lot crazy
and and without any acting experience
was there like a stumbling period did
you feel at all insecure
yeah and not not because i was not good
it was because they were not nice to me
they were not
and i i remember
you know people like to
they like to claim me too they're like
oh
alumni yeah you guys were such [ __ ]
to me i just remember except my co-star
david davidson he was he was amazing um
but like the producers and like the the
people the the producers and directors
there was only like three rotating
directors and you know in soaps they
they do the voice of god so they don't
direct you
in person they're like or
even if you could just move to the right
eva more to the right more to thank you
and i remember there's this horrible
woman director
and
you know
i would be like oh hey you know
so and so i have a question and she's
like oh my god what what
what
and i'm like oh i just i just was like
it would be great do you think i could
cross on this line instead of this line
because i feel oh my god eva yeah do it
and i'd be like okay okay oh okay just
because and then i remember one time
there was an actor his line would that's
his line was like
oh my line was like
no he goes where do you think you're
going and i go i'll tell you where i'm
going
right so they go you know they don't say
action they say 5432
and uh and he goes
what do you think you're doing
and i go i'll tell you what i'm
where i'm going and they go cut eva
and i go i blamed it on you no i'm sorry
he has to say you
you your line is where you going right
because i tell you where i'm going and
he goes yeah yeah that's what i said and
i go oh okay and then i was like oh i
told him i [ __ ] up i misheard him so
then he goes
he goes comes in and he goes so what's
up
and i go
i'll tell you what's up
right i was like i'm gonna make it work
yeah yeah yeah i'll fix it i get it back
out i'll get this train back on that's
right and they go cut eva could you just
say the line yes
and i was like okay but you know my you
know my line is going he has to say
where are you going so i can say i'll
tell you where i'm going and they were
like could you just just say the line
and i was like oh my gosh and it was
like that almost every day almost every
day it was it oh
it was not a fun job and i remember they
fired me uh
holy [ __ ] it's like the dumb and the
restless that's crazy well they just let
me out of my contract they're like yeah
we have nowhere to go because i was a
crazy person on the show um oh i've like
murdered people and and um and i was so
ha i was like yeah yeah totally good i'm
good thank you so much i bet yeah yeah i
bet and i love that isn't that crazy
that now they try to claim you as like
oh she was one of an alum from god did
we love her and i was like you guys
weren't very nice to me
um that's so crazy wow what what what do
you attribute that to do you think it's
um
your youth your your heritage your your
your spa i mean what i don't know but i
did i did one time say could you do it
more latin
oh man i was like i don't you're like i
don't uh one of the directors actually
told me she's like if you could do it
more like rosie perez and i was like
who has the most specific voice and a
speech impediment
[Laughter]
like
that's beyond an accent a charming one
yeah that's beyond an accent like she's
from the bronx and i love bro let me
tell you i love me some roses oh i love
it i just why are you going why are you
going to love wow
i just can't do a rosie perez
no one can only rosie perez can do it
right right and i i feel like that's
what they wanted and i wasn't that girl
i mean like i wow yeah yeah
yeah don't do it you're such an
american texan like cheerleaders super
american apple pie i was like i don't
that's an accent
i mean do you want a brooklyn a bronx
accent i didn't even know what it was
i was so confused
why well it makes sense that i mean like
especially i mean you must have seen
such a
such a change when it comes to that like
the parts that are now uh available you
know
and all
all the representation but how much it
must have changed how much it is
changing things for younger
uh actors you know who don't have to but
you must have been asked to do
countless times like can you do an ax
can you do a mexican accent or whatever
yeah oh yeah yeah can you do it with an
accent was my and it's so funny because
i have a really great friend rosalyn
sanchez who has a beaut
friend friend of the show yes she was on
a couple yeah she has a beautiful accent
she's from puerto rico she's like we
were on a show together
at a crop show we run la dragnet the new
the new la dragon oh yeah neil the dick
wolf and uh
and you know it was like perp and you
know oh we got to catch the purple uh
book of him
get his dob and all this stuff and she
had she had some line like ballistics
and she goes what the [ __ ] is a
ballistic i don't know what a ballistic
is and i was like i think it's
roz it's ballistic i don't know why it's
fingerprinting why can't i say bingo
printing and i'm like okay well i think
you should stick with ballistic
and so every time i would go into on an
audition
for a girl with an accent i would be
like have you seen a girl named rosin
sanchez because she's amazing
[Laughter]
and my agent called me she's like if you
pitch rosin sanchez in an audition one
more time
i used to do that i used to pitch uh
jason ritter all the time it's like
there's a guy jason ritter i really
think you should get him for this
he is phenomenal i would always pick my
thing was rosalind i was like have you
guys seen her she's amazing
uh that's really sweet and funny that's
such a great instinct but also true i
have a very personal question oh god um
i read that you are genetically
distantly related to yo yo ma yes
is that is that you mean is that true
and meryl streep
who cares about meryl streep but yo yo
ma uh no that's amazing yeah so that
that dna thing that i did
they do six other people on the show so
in my show it was stephen colbert
yo-yo ma meryl streep
myself and i forget the other two
they cross-reference our dna
to see if we if you've shared a relative
in the last 100 years and
yo-yo ma and i share a distant relative
and oh wow meryl streep and i so i i was
at the golden globes backstage and i see
meryl streep and i'm like oh that's a
great thing to get through i was like
i'm not gonna go up to her i'm not gonna
go hey oh i'm related
and she goes she sees me she goes cousin
and i was like
oh yeah oh my god oh my god my head
exploded
if you screamed as loud as you did when
we first saw each other
i can only imagine
i can only imagine your reaction oh my
god i love how cool that she not only
knew but did it in such a she was the
one she did because i was like i'm not
i'm not going up to meryl streep and not
only that she goes oh cousin i was like
oh my god
and then i go well you
you obviously got the talent in the
family and she goes well you obviously
got the beauty like oh
she was like i will never ever forget
that conversation ah
yeah yeah god that
that must make up for years of ugly i
know and i was like wait does that mean
i'm not talented as well
that's true that's how i would have
taken it that's that's true
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
hello hello again so we'll meet again
[Music]
i read uh also another uh internet find
that you were set up set up on a date
with your now husband yeah
and he and he didn't know who you were
he he
i mean he by the way he's in the tv
industry so he knew of desperate
housewives like he's like oh yeah that
was a big show because he he was yeah he
was in spanish language tv and
his um network did not carry desperate
housewives so he had never watched it
and um so it was the competitor so he's
like i'm not watching that uh
and
yeah a friend of mine introduced us i
met him
i was like hello hello and uh and
that's really nothing
no sparks nothing all i remember oh
nothing but like nothing all i remember
was we were both reading the same book
which was crazy
because it was a kabbalah book like i'm
not a cabalist i don't know why somebody
gave this book
and it was called satan
and
it's about the ego
and i remember always flying and being
on a flight and it says satan and i'm
like oh this is a book of ideas it's not
about satanism and i would like always
have to explain it to people like i was
like i'm reading it but this is a book
about ego it's not about satan
um
and so i just i remember distinctly
reading that book because people would
give me a sign that's a book you want to
read fast yeah i bet you on a plate
that's really funny and then he goes i'm
reading that book and i said oh my gosh
and he goes yeah isn't it fascinating
and we had a conversation about the book
and then that was it and then six months
later we re-met through the same friend
and i and it like
it was like fireworks like it was like
whoa and i was like who where is that
and my friend's like that's pepe i've
been trying that's the guy i introduced
you to and i go that's not the guy
that's not the guy he goes that's the
guy you met at the back in the you know
where he didn't know who you were and i
was like that's not that's not the guy
that's not the guy i don't know who that
guy was but this guy is amazing
oh my god that's so
weird and then did it dawn on you then
did it come back to you that you had it
yeah i mean it was obviously him but i i
don't
own i couldn't i couldn't pick him out
of a lineup if you told me like that wha
wha what do you think what do you
attribute that i think i think it's
about timing and i think it's when
you're you're open to the universe like
i was coming out of a relationship he
was going through a breakup but even for
him he wasn't like oh my god i blew it
with evil like no he was well in in the
interim he had watched a bunch of
desperate housewives episodes which by
the way he still hasn't
and we tried we tried i actually made i
was like we're gonna watch we gotta
watch it and then i'm sleeping with
everybody and i was like you know what
you know you don't need to watch it you
don't need to watch it wait we're fine
you're fine it doesn't you know it was a
big deal back in the day just know that
okay
[Laughter]
just know
i can get into some restaurants a little
bit easier
yeah
[Laughter]
what how quickly did things change on
that show like once that show because
that was such a massive did that was it
like i know overnight but it was
overnight like it it's
that's not an expert it's not it's not
an expression in this case because i
remember wow we premiered with lost like
lost was the big uh show and
right and you know everybody passed on
desperate housewives no not one network
wanted it not lifetime passed on
desperate housewives oh
abc was like in the tank it was like the
lowest rated network they were just they
were desperate
and uh and then they were like yeah
let's let's you know let's roll the dice
on this
and so
loss premiered at like 17 million
and we were like and they were the
sunday they were before they were the
week before us and i was like oh my god
that's insane
oh my god like biggest premiere ever of
a tv show i don't even remember and then
next week we premiered and we were like
30 million it was something insane
and oprah called the next day we were on
oprah
we were
like i remember the next day everybody
was on set like extra and access
hollywood and e and true hollywood the
true hollywood stories i was like oh
hollywood stories did i did am i did i
fall off the
well i didn't have i killed kill
somebody already did i go on drugs what
happened like oh remember the each
hollywood story like immediately came
out ended and i was like oh my god what
happened and it was so fast
that
it was almost so fast that it didn't
affect me during like it was like yeah
yeah yeah you didn't have time to adjust
you just were working so we were like
just working keep your head down and you
keep moving
right and you're on the lot right you
guys did most of that stuff yeah yeah
everything which is a big part of that
tour now that must be surreal for you
that that is now a part of i remember
being on was it universal yeah was it uh
yeah
i remember shooting something there and
like taking that to her all the time
taking the train
going by
there's been many times i've i've gone
back because i'll be shooting something
else a lot and i'll go into my house
because it's still there
and when the tram when the tram comes by
i pop out and then oh that's great
really oh and they're like oh my gosh
she lives there
has she just been there the whole time
they have working they have plumbing in
that
that's so crazy oh people must freak
they must go yeah yeah and then i
remember like we would we would do it
all the time we would [ __ ] with the
trams and then we got a a letter one
time going don't [ __ ] with the trams
like please
don't oh really because it's like the
biggest money making thing is that oh
yeah
like not only the theme park but the
tran the tour the universal tour yes oh
yeah and there's like one every two
minutes i mean i would think though i
would think they would like that i would
think they would encourage you to do no
no you would really be like
you know oh
oh okay well it depends on what you do
to the tram i guess throwing eggs
get out of here
yeah get out of your [ __ ] tourists
yeah abusing themselves don't take my
phone
that'd be funny that'd be funny to be
like don't take a peer from that set
yeah but but people must also approach
you like
like they know you like like and like
you've you've done something scandalous
yourself because of the character you
played do you get do you get that a lot
like uh how could how could you sleep
with trevor
stuff like that
yeah or are they always like i love you
and carlos why aren't you with carlos
and i'm like
because he's not my husband uh and so he
yeah a lot of that but you know it was
it was a global phenomenon because i
remember
in the united states it was huge but
like it was huge in france and huge in
the uk and huge in australia really and
he like so i remember you know i
remember going the first time we had to
go to the uk because uk was like
three months behind it wasn't like oh
next year you'll get it it was like very
yeah close to us and we went to this
press junket in the
in the hotel and we went to our we
landed we go to this hotel and there's
like fans out
all the way down the street and i go oh
my god
bono must be here like who is here yeah
somebody the spice girls must be here
like oh my god i was and so i asked the
lady i was like who's here this is
insane we can't even get in the hotel
and they go
you
oh my god because it was all of us it
was like i mean it was like a couple of
and i was like yeah
this is it somebody
important must be here i mean this is
this is a lot of people she's like i
mean i mean bono's here too but people
aren't really like lining up for it
was like
this must be for me
that must be however he talks
uh no bono sorry um
wow this is so hard because i don't want
to end this and i i have to get now um
we have a lightning round oh my god okay
hold on hold on let me parchment okay
eva is what is that drink lemonade yeah
ish lemonade-ish it's a sparkling
probiotic lemon ginger
oh it is delicious it's so good
kavita a little shout out i um
don't like kombucha but it is it is
kombucha e
oh that's good to know because i'm not
crazy about the taste of kombucha but i
i want the healthcare items
this is a sparkling probiotic and it's
okay
and um
yeah live probiotics so
hey there you go maybe they'll send us
some
what do you think
um
uh what
what is your favorite emoji
this one
the prayer uh the hands together the
prayer yes i love that one i find it
really useful
yeah what's yours i can't imagine that's
not yeah it's not yours
uh it's that and it's also the kind of
looking down smile the sort of like
submissive slightly submissive well this
one is my new one
uh hand to the head i use that a lot yup
a lot of that i've been using this one a
lot a little like
that one's a good one
i can't even find it
i can't ever yeah
it's it's in my regular rotation and as
is the this like oh yeah
i do that one a lot like i like i i do
it in the context of like i know this is
a dumb joke but uh sorry it's kind of
like a song
the teeth together
um who was your first celebrity medudo
oh okay uh did you ever get to meet him
and he's one of my best friends um
oh yeah because i made him but i was on
i can see that by the way i can see that
happening i can see you forcing someone
to be your best friend we're going to be
best friends
yeah okay
he lives literally down the street right
now because i was like this is where you
have to live yeah we're going to live
close to each other he oh he lives on
mysteriously
but he's um i know this is lightning
round but i met him on a red carpet
at mtv awards and i was presenting like
it was my first mtv i don't even know
and they were like who do you most
wanted me
here and i was like i hear that ricky
martin's here
and i met him when i was 14.
um i stood in i stood in line for two
hours when he was in menudo and um and i
had a polaroid picture of us and um i'm
gonna meet him i'm gonna meet him and
they're like he's
you're like he'll remember
in corpus christi and um
yeah i was i was 13 and he was right
behind me they go well he's right behind
you and he goes oh my god that's such a
sweet story and i was like i love you so
much and then i i think i climbed on him
and
held him
and yeah like a man he was very
uncomfortable
uh but now he's one of my best friends
oh that's cool i i'd like to was this
was this before he came out was this
when you it was still like a potential
for
and we're going to be boyfriend
um yes no i think it was after he he'd
come out maybe
i'd also like to point out that that
you're so professional that in the both
times you screamed the several times you
you've instinctively backed away from
them it's almost like a singer's
instinct of like when they go it is
yeah
yeah i love when they do this with their
hand like they trace the note they
follow the note
do you sing are you no people say that
they go oh my god is there anything you
can't do because i i do everything and i
go i don't see it
okay
um what is your favorite ice cream
flavor vanilla
okay what does that say about me what
does that say about me i don't know but
people might want to ascribe
some some blandness to it or that but
it's obviously if they've heard the this
interview they they know that that can't
be the case yeah um well it's a good
basis for everything else it's a great
base yeah that you can mix stuff with
and also vanilla is delicious yeah
vanilla a vanilla milkshake oh my god
what
um yeah what is your favorite holiday
oh it's a toss-up between halloween and
thanksgiving oh yeah i think minus two
with july yeah independence day a little
bit um
no not for you it's yeah maybe it's a
little different historically
i just like grill i like barbecues i
like gatherings yeah they're like
outdoors that's why i love thanksgiving
because i'm a big kid yes and and and
christmas is so much about gifts and
presents and like i know it's not my
favorite thing although i like christmas
time like i like lights up and i like
christmas songs yeah i love a christmas
tree but but as far as like i really
love thanksgiving
for the meal because that also has
horrible historical
uh yes
yeah yes i know i know what is an
acclaimed movie that you're embarrassed
to admit you haven't seen that people
shame you for you haven't seen blah blah
blah all the godfathers
okay yes
okay yep
well what is preventing what is the just
every time i watch the first one i fall
asleep and so i'm like not gonna watch
two and three
well
that's true well the first
i would that's a good point because a
lot of the first one is quite slow so
slow
what is a game show pastor president
that you'd want to be a contestant on oh
i i would like the newlywed game
because oh yeah i find that fun um
but i probably want to play with like my
best friend like me and my best friend
because we know each other
yeah
that's kind of cheating
we know each other so well
do you drink coffee or tea and if so how
do you take it coffee i drink it every i
drink it black in the morning like in
the in the morning morning just black
then about 11 o'clock i'll have a cafe
cubano which is
a very serious process it's sweet right
it's just sweeter it's very sweet cafe
cobano is very sweet i don't make it as
sweet but yeah yes and you make it with
cream i do put lactose-free milk ah okay
if you could learn another language what
would it be well i speak french and i
speak spanish
and so oh wow those are useful i well
yeah my so my second language was french
because of my ex-husband then i learned
spanish so oh wow
because of my husband so if i got
married a fourth time it would be to an
italian yeah
oh just to learn the language just to
learn italian which is by the way
useless in the world because only you
only speak italian in italy
i know i know but what a great i know
but still what a great country um what
is your favorite cereal um basic four
it's oh i remember basically before
healthy
but i love it it's
oh yeah and after that a really close
second fruity pebbles oh yeah we again
forbidden fruit forbidden fruity pebbles
when we were kids we could never have
yeah if you could choose if you had to
choose a different first name
uh what would it be um
you know my my name is eva jacqueline
longoria my mom named me after
jacqueline onassis because she was
obsessed with jackie oh yeah
and so i i tried to make people call me
jackie when i was young and it never
never caught on it never took never
how do you do that where people just
like no yeah
yes
yeah i was like you guys my name is
jackie my mom's like evil let's go god
damn it
if you um that's funny if you if you had
a sandwich named after you the eva
longoria what what would be on it what
would your ideal concoction be it'd be a
lot of meats like salami and ham and
turkey
and
and i'm a big provolone fan
and i like uh lettuce and pickles and
mayonnaise and i like i'm just naming
you my subway sandwich is what i'm doing
yeah yeah uh-huh
okay
and then they're just just oh and
baloney and bologna baloney oh yes god i
used to love bologna
yes um what is your what what's your
favorite tom hanks movie oh oh that's a
good question oh
he's putting her hands to her mouth as
if um
just recently felt re fell in love with
him like i was like realizing how many
yeah big
hands down yeah hands down yeah would
you rather take a time machine to the
past or the future oh the past
oh easily oh yeah
a particular era a particular oh
all of them i mean i i i
1603 you can meet i know but it was the
black plague during that i don't i just
don't want to oh maybe
yes i want to be in another pandemic
i know i want to go during a healthy
time after jonas salk after they like
you know after advance after penicillin
yeah um yeah uh yeah it's i feel like
beef more
before the first world war
after light was in 1890s so the light
bulb
maybe later you know yes
yeah okay that's um are you more a
talker or a texter when you communicate
with friends
brittany i'm a voice knight
neuter oh me too i'm a voice noiter too
i i love a good voice noit i do
i'm always leaving them i i love you i
hate texting and i hate calling yes
yes yes me too wow okay cool
um
uh why is that cool right and it's
somebody because because it's the same
thing as calling by the way but then if
i if it uh no no
no because it doesn't the the other
person doesn't have the opportunity to
to to
potentially drone on like i'm doing um
night are you at night or are you a
night or morning person morning
okay yeah i'm asleep and you must hit
the ground running i was i'm a oh really
like eight or nine yeah um
yeah i hit the ground running
beach or mountains would you prefer
beach beach beach beach beach yep yep
okay um and do you have any opinion
about toilet roll over or under oh yes i
do i have a very strong opinion about
this i get so upset
and about in public spaces i change it i
i'm like this is wrong
if there's a bathroom i've been in that
that toilet paper is over yes
okay
thank you
um now finish the sentence if you will
life is short so
so
uh be true to yourself yes
well said
um
little pedro would be proud
what a great uh you are such uh love
like you're such a fun impressive person
i i so enjoy this is why i felt like you
should do
podcast me yeah i was like you were
right and but now eva i'm thinking like
what you said you were like you said
something self-deprecating like oh you
know what this is what i thought you
were going to like change your mind you
were like
actually i'm not i will i won't be good
i'm not a good i'm not good at this kind
of stuff this is
this is hard to end i'm only ending it
because i know you have to go and i have
a six o'clock thing i know i i was like
i don't really like talking to people oh
my that's what you said yes you're an
incredible talker i don't know what
you're talking about um no but i've been
such a huge fan of yours from afar
such a such a huge fan and and i love
following you on instagram and you oh
you really make me smile and you make me
laugh and you've been doing that for a
while and i thought you should know
oh man well god you have really done
that for me here this has been so
enjoyable
thanks for saying that i'm blushing
so that just
happened
i didn't know how to approach the runway
for the landing um
you can't do an impression i can't
really with a female voice like that
it's she has a unique laugh
yeah
yes how would you um
it's boisterous it's well it's sort of
like um it's body
michelle
our intrepid executive producer mish
pointed out that it sounds a bit like
the count oh my god
and once she said that i couldn't i
couldn't
stop i couldn't not think that
oh my god
yes oh my god i don't think she'd be
insulted by that either no she seems
like somebody
who it would be very difficult to insult
does it doesn't it i'm glad you didn't
try how
because of her upbringing the three
siblings who were constantly calling her
you know that little dark one
ugly dark one oh it wasn't the little i
thought it was a little one wait wait i
wrote it down you brought it up like 40
times like i couldn't get past i know
because it's like
she's so and she's so cute and like you
know now obviously she's become like a
star and she's beauty campaigns and
stuff um so she's known to be a pretty
person
it's fascinating that how your
upbringing
i mean this is like duh can directly
impact your personality as an adult and
oh in your case
being the youngest and being
kind of teased
was a strengthened her
completely strengthened her yeah like
made her because now she is
like i don't think anyone could hear
this episode and not think
holy [ __ ] is she
funny funny and cool and oh my god down
to earth like
so impressive i hope this isn't like an
inherently insulting thing to say but i
was so surprised by how funny she was
why can you unpack that well because she
is i've thought of her
my perception of her was that she's like
kind of like in the fashion world and
and she does like dramas stuff you know
she's more like kind of like desperate
house was my perception of that was that
i don't know i i've never seen her in
like funny thing i've never associated
her with the work she's done with funny
things although but then when i was
thinking about it like she's done funny
or die stuff she's i then started
remembering the funny things i've seen
her in
i guess also it's my prejudice about
like good looking people well i will say
i think she's like one of the funniest
women
i've i haven't met her but oh heard from
a long time
funnier than a lot of comedians i'll
also say
she's married so i'm i don't i'm not
implying anything by this but you guys
have incredible chemistry together yeah
oh i i and
when she said right at the top of the
interview and she said you know i used
to think of like if i got married to you
my name would be eva long
i
put myself in your shoes and i imagine
myself being quite excited by her saying
something like that oh yeah that's
interesting when she said that i took it
in a less romantic way oh really yeah
yeah because it seems like i was
eavesdropping on like the best first
date that that's how it felt well you
like really like finished each other's
sentences she was really nice really
enjoyed her company her like
conversation i felt like a real like
friendship with her it felt like a real
friendly vibe maybe you'll be friends
with her i would like to see the start
of a beautiful friendship i would like
to i could i could see myself i rarely
feel that anymore where where like i'm
you know you meet somebody you think i
could be i could it'd be fun to be
friends with that person she'd be a fun
friend to have she's funny funny and
like she's into like yeah and i feel
like
easy you can like i know
i know that's what i'm saying like can i
be friends with her too sure come out
with us and i i'd like to meet her
husband too because i'd like to know i'm
sure he's great oh for sure he's great
it's also like
she has been through other marriages and
like i think once you
i think once you've been through serious
relationships like that you man you get
to a certain age you
you i mean i'm projecting onto her but
like you really get to know you have a
real strong sense of what you want and
like what you're looking for in a part
who you are and who you are exactly yeah
and so
i i can only imagine i assume that her
husband is like equally like cool i like
when you go in really confident about
something oh man i know you're gonna say
you're completely wrong oh my god you
just didn't read it right on the on the
sheet the question i
know you you go
you're like oh my god i didn't know this
i just grew up only speaking spanish i
wanted it and you said like you don't
ask it when you're confident about
something you like say it in a very
declared statement of fact i didn't know
this yeah this is what you did and she
was like it's actually the opposite oh
man but of course because she's cool she
made it funny and like easy and you
transitioned out of that potentially
awkward moment you could have very
easily a less cool person could have
easily like gone to town on that one
could have really dined out on that
could have like shamed me and
you know i am been offended i was so
struck by it in the moment because of
because of she had no semblance of an
accent and i was surprised to learn that
she didn't speak any spanish growing up
uh you know no living in corpus christi
that's also surprising it is right
they're both surprising in different
ways but but then when you want when she
unpacked it it shouldn't be i mean it
was like fascinating history i know 13
generations i just read about that um
about the border moving up and down yes
i always forget the name of it the end
of the myth the end of the myth yeah
great book book i wanted to recommend it
have you finished that no i want to i'm
finished it's a great book i'm going on
i can't wait to highly recommend but
it's about that the myth being
uh american exceptionalism and how we've
always had this like inherent spirit of
you know
progressiveness and and inclusion and
when in fact it's really like the
country was founded on sort of the
opposite well and all the stuff about
the mexican-american war which i don't
remember learning at all i know school
like growing up i unless i was just not
paying attention for part of it i
remember it being so heavily school
being so heavily focused on the american
revolution and the civil war
and like that's it kind of in terms of
american history
that was heavy uh yeah i know and what
we did to the mexicans who were already
there just living in mexico when it was
they just stayed there yeah and they
created this arbitrary
border around them yeah it's really
fascinating oh we digress anyway yes but
it's a really cool history and she's
distantly related to meryl streep and
yo-yo ma
would you rather that's a question would
you rather be just distantly related to
meryl streep or yo-yo ma
um
hmm
i know what i'd answer if i were you for
sure well meryl streep maybe you think
no the opposite because then and be like
well you should be a better actor
exactly not to say you're not a better
actor yes i know no it's but it's like
really you have meryl streep's blood in
you and you're not like it's like weird
high stakes i know that's true it's how
i always felt about tom cruise's like
half brother he's a good actor william
mapathor oh yeah mapathar it's amazing
when she said there's not a minute
that i wasted a day i know
it's completely unsurprising oh and then
i thought about all the ways i wasted
that knowing of her yeah oh my god it's
so she's like goals i know it's a really
great because she's like i mean
she doesn't waste any minutes
but she also like you told her is she's
very present yeah and seems easy going
no it's not some like
type
no i know it's like frenetic like it's
really something to aspire to that she
is like
really i mean it's like our life is
short don't waste time like really make
the most out of your days yeah and makes
the most out of it and i like what she
said about and she also seems to to live
this how she said um life is short so be
true to yourself i like that she seems
like she is really
really follows that dictum well your
bono impression is amazing
we should try to get him on the show so
you could do it for him
you know who we should get on the show
is sting
ooh you know his mickey mickey sumner
yeah or his daughter his daughter anna's
dying
yeah um
trudy but mickey i know pretty well
but mickey's oh we should also get
mickey on the show she's a good actress
let's get everyone on the show okay
um yeah
man she's great she's funny and you like
you said she's just easy and and i like
i meant that i i had to stop and i knew
she did too but i got to talk to her for
hours
i'm kind of glad that she is so
scheduled yes i know because i wonder
how she would have said because that
could have been one of those four-hour
episodes that has run into the ground
yeah
i know it is a real um
she's really inspiring way to to live to
be like because my maybe this is what i
tell myself to make myself feel better
for being like a little lazier but like
you're right i i always think of people
who those type a people who fill up the
whole day and like everything's
regimented i always think of them as
being like high strung and rot you know
like kind of nervous not being really
present
the fact that she's able to live that
way
and be so
present and like easy like chill kind of
and not that she'd want to do it or a
good listener too
not that she'd want to do it or would be
available for it but don't you want to
write a movie
that uh like a part for her oh my god a
comedy she's so funny
that's true i wouldn't be available by
how funny she was i know not shocked
like i didn't no but i'm not absolutely
insulting about that i know i don't i
don't think she would be unfunny but i
didn't realize how funny she was no i
know and also like well you can tell
about somebody on from instagram like
i do follow her i i like she doesn't
often put she posts i don't know she
doesn't offer she posts a lot of like
philanthropic stuff obviously and
um but i i i
yeah but also she does she is one of
those people that does
so much
charity work but
she does not brag about it or
she doesn't seem self-righteous about it
i know or virtue signaling no a lot of
stuff she said does without actually
like posting about it but again like she
said is the way she grew up she grew up
yeah uh
learning
that the volunteerism was that was
normal very important part of life yeah
the fact that she doesn't have memories
of thanksgiving like sitting around the
table
that her memories of thanksgiving were
like serving people i know i mean what
more do you need to know don't you want
to kind of like don't you want to talk
to her mother and just be like
how did you do it maybe a future guest i
you know i'm curious because i want to
raise a kid like that
you know that's parental goals i think
let's read a letter okay
from bill gennall
g-a-n-a-h-l
subject an unlikely listener
huh hi i'm so curious hi justin
christian just want to let you know that
you have listeners in what might be
unlikely places
i work in a hot rod shop building old
custom cars cool
and i listen to podcasts while i cut
grind and weld metal wow that's [ __ ]
i so admire i wish i could do that don't
you yeah
i have many hours to fill every day so i
listen to a lot of podcasts along with
plenty of music and yours is one of the
few that stays in constant rotations oh
man thank you bill
um
back to bill i'm not absolutely sure but
i would assume that a lot of people in
my industry listen to fox news and or
billy ray cyrus all day every day i
don't follow new country music so please
excuse the outdated reference which is
less of a political statement than
simply a judgment about their tastes in
general
well i i wonder i would imagine trying
to think like when i go to those auto
body shops like what i usually hear and
now i'm trying to think about the
current uh contemporary oh yeah blake
shelton i think is really popular now
he's luke bryan is probably still
probably luke bryan remember yeah
with luke bryan we did we had like
super famous luke bryan yeah to the
point when night out with him in las
vegas yeah i remember when he was great
he was so nice so fun we had a fun night
i hope he's still nice
uh you know after he seems like all this
success we should try to get him on the
show oh yeah that'd be great i wouldn't
remember that i wonder if he does i bet
he does don't you remember him being
like man i hope i'll make it like he had
that kind of energy like my and like he
was really like humble and
yeah he was great um
anyway yeah that's a good reference
but
but regardless of my gross leads back to
bill but regardless of my grossly
stereotyping other people in my own peer
group you guys not only choose excellent
guests there are very few who i don't
know or care to listen to but now i'm
curious who those are but justin's
interview style is both subtle and
engaging somehow you make celebrities
seem more completely down to earth and
approachable wow how good do you feel
really good thanks bill especially after
that letter from a couple weeks ago
where it was like you don't do enough
research anyway back to bill it's
unbelievable that no one has slammed
their headphones down and walked out of
the interview after being asked who
their favorite muppet is
well i don't think people are that
passionate
back to bill and that is a testament to
justin's ability to bring people back to
a place of humbleness and humility which
is refreshing and restores my faith in
humanity wow
what a nice thing to read thank you bill
um what really prompted me to write was
a would you rather that i came up with
great based partially on my occupation
but also on my and my wife's love of
travel
would you rather not be able to drive
ever again or not to travel ever again
this means you would have to use public
transportation or lyft or whatever to
get around on a daily basis if you
wanted to be able to travel anywhere
outside of the continent
this is actually slightly complicated
because you technically wouldn't be able
to go on road trips if you chose
traveling other than driving over
driving um
you could still fly anywhere but you
wouldn't be able to drive there i grew
up in a road trip family we only flew
once that i can remember as a kid oh we
did too
only once which is partially because my
dad was a cheapskate but also because
he's six foot eight and can't can't fit
on planes whoa
so i have an affection for the road trip
and i build cars and drive old cars
which i really love to drive my wife and
i just got back from a 4 000 mile road
trip whoa in our 1964 buick riviera holy
[ __ ]
they drove a 1964 buick riviera
4 000 miles that's nuts
but we also fly all over the world and
would like to explore an adventure
outside of the us which i don't know if
i could give up i honestly don't know
what i would choose if i were forced
this exercise hurts my brain and my soul
thank you for the podcast and please
keep them coming bill gone off oh man
thanks bill i want to think about this
would you rather um
does so is would you rather not be able
to drive it does the traveling
i mean just vacate like pleasurable i
think traveling anywhere
so you mean like a practical trap yeah
like for work like if you have to go to
la for work would you have to yeah get
in the car
you'd have to use a lift or uber or
something or um on a daily basis he says
on a daily basis
oh i thought it was oh wait this means
you would have to use public
transportation or lyft or whatever to
get around on a daily basis if you
wanted to be able to travel anywhere
outside of the continent
i'm confused
this hurts my brain too would you rather
not be able to see it
i thought it was i thought the options
were
driving like driving a car and if you
you can either do that or not do it ever
again
everywhere public transportation
or
um
travel anywhere like
you know outside the country on a plane
like vacation yeah i guess so i guess
that's what it is
not be able to drive everything so it's
like which would you rather give up
that's how i but that's why he said with
the with the road trip let me see with
the with the travel with the rope but
then you could do a vacation road trip
yes so that's that would be your
vacation yes but you couldn't leave the
country for instance to vacation
yes i think that's what it is
that's really tough because
i mean obviously driving and i'm
assuming he means just a car would you
rather go he said this is actually
slowly come to get complicated because
you technically wouldn't be able to go
on road trips if you chose traveling
traveling over driving
oh so you still wouldn't be able to do
that even
you wouldn't be able to go on road trips
yeah so it's
yeah i mean that's hard it's hard
because
driving a car is like 99
i know of
of the answer in a way yeah or whatever
it's a high percentage of the amount of
time you do these things but to be left
but to give up i know traveling i mean
i'm just thinking about how enriched
i've been by like
i'm thinking about japan specifically or
like god iceland
i know but then think about after we
record this you're going to the gym i
know think about having to get a lift
there instead of just hopping in your
car and driving and you know especially
this van i have this like camper van
built that um
was uh i i i got during the pandemic and
i just love driving it around and i love
the idea i just road trips for me are
too pretty maybe you found a loophole
and as would you rather you have that
you have your creeper van yeah so it's
not it's not a typical car
and now
no no he says no driving he says yeah
would you not would you rather not be
able to drive ever again i think i would
have to give up travel that hurts my
brain too yeah i know it does because
both are so
or you know you do it's really tough or
this or you just get used to not driving
and you get used to getting an uber
anytime you need to do it and you live
you move
to a part of town or city
that is heavily dependent on walking or
public transportation so
it makes driving kind of absolutely yeah
um and you get used to which is
something i'd like to do actually is
uh it wouldn't be like that bad of a
second choice to take trains
all throughout the country if you want
to see the because i love seeing the
country i love going driving through the
you know the harping and all that like
that would be cool to take you could
take a train through there also driving
i don't like part of driving for me like
i don't have what he has
what bill has which is this love for
cars this lovely classic cars and like
the driving itself i have a like from
classical yeah but like i you know i
drive a prius so i'm not like i don't
have this passion for cars
but i do i do enjoy
the time i have driving i like the alone
time i like the meditative quality i do
too it'd be really hard to give that up
but i think
i think i might have to because i really
aspire
in my life to seeing more of the world
and
to turn that switch off now that'd be
really hard it would be i think a big
mistake in my life i think i would have
to force myself
to not drive you know i don't think i'm
considering enough my the control
element of being behind a wheel and all
of the enjoyment that i've had from like
god i think back to like when i was
first just going out into the world i i
was just i just had this flash of
shooting japanese crappies uh in ocala
county and cheapest creepers creepers um
and and getting to like just drive
through those like that flat like
spanish moss like this just horse
country and how much enjoyment like
listening to music i know but then think
about all the european countries you
went to
and central american countries too and
that's all gone i know this is bill this
is that's a this is hurting my brain
better yeah thanks a lot bill but i
think i would give up driving i think
i think i'd give up traffic and just
rethink how i function day-to-day well
thanks bill our brains and hearts hurt
now uh but also thank you for got such
kind words and it's so cool to imagine
he's right i would never have guessed
that somebody working in a shop in an
auto body shop would be like listening
to
i would never think that evil longoria
is the funniest i know lady in show
business
yeah who would have made discoveries in
this episode um thanks bill and if you
guys would like to write in our email
address is life is short at wondery.com
and we really do love getting these
letters yes um you both have to love
getting letters on the podcast that you
do uh and so and thanks to eva man what
a
what a fun what a fun episode good
episode really good episode really
strong app strong and like a whole i'd
love to hang out with her in the world
and her husband
truly they'd be good like couple friends
tev let's see if you can make that
happen one day okay um and thanks to all
of you for listening and we'll talk at
you next week
we'll talk in your ears next week
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life sure is hosted by me justin long
it is co-hosted and produced by you
christian long it's also produced by
megan v monaco and katie v allen senior
producer on this is michelle
and we have ourselves an audio engineer
sergio enriquez and the executive
producer's name rhymes with darshal pooy
marshall louie for a wandery
[Music]
there's a lot of yelling in that episode
you guys yelled a lot we did because you
know i couldn't really hear her oh
really yeah i i couldn't hear myself
that well
excited i think it was fun it was
passionate though
this is part of the episode yeah oh okay
so are you apologizing maybe i should
apologize maybe this is the voice memo
oh
whoa okay interesting so new it's a new
take on it so let's bring it down to
prepare people for next episode since
that there was a lot of yelling in that
i was yelling because i couldn't it was
fun yelling it wasn't angry i know i was
like oh my god and she did a lot of that
yeah it was fine all right yeah she i
but but she was she tended to be more
mindful of the mic
i even said that she moved back she'd
move back she'd be like ah
something you can learn from her
something i hope you did learn from her
okay bye bye sorry
you